Let's go
to let's go to Tyler from the 6 5 0.
We haven't heard from Tyler in 2020.
What's going on, Tyler?
Hey, David.
How's it going?
Can you hear me?
Yes, I can.
Hey, I was just calling in just to see how
you were doing during this quarantine time.
And also, I had a quick question about Joe
Biden.
Sure.
Yeah.
I mean, listen, I've I wreck it's I don't
love the quarantine.
I'm bored, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
You know, it's more that it's more claustrophobia
than boredom.
But I recognize that I've not lost my job.
I have food to eat.
You know, I recognize that I do not have it
anywhere near as bad as millions and millions
of people do.
And I'm just taking it a day at a time, basically.
Tyler.
All right.
Well, Tyler's gun would have loved to have
heard that Joe Biden question.
But anyway, at least I got that first part,
the first part out there for you guys.